otro avance diplomático en medio oriente
marruecos e israel volverán a
restablecer relaciones diplomáticas
después de casi dos décadas desde
jerusalén el primer ministro israelí
celebró la decisión creo que esta es la
base sobre la que ahora podemos
construir la paz
reanudaremos las oficinas de enlace
rápidamente entre israel y marruecos y
trabajaremos lo más rápido posible para
establecer relaciones diplomáticas
plenas
también instituir hemos vuelos directos
entre marruecos israel e israel y
marruecos dando a este puente de paz una
base aún más sólida
marruecos se convierte así en el cuarto
país en restablecer relaciones con el
estado hebreo este año luego de emiratos
árabes unidos bahrein y sudan a cambio
de este gesto eeuu mediador en el
acuerdo reconoció la soberanía de
marruecos sobre el sahara occidental un
territorio disputado por marroquíes y
separatistas del frente polisario
apoyado por argelia algo que ninguna
otra nación occidental había hecho hasta
ahora
y gracias al trabajo realizado durante
los últimos tres años por su majestad
del rey a través de emisarios a través
de contactos directos a través de una
participación hoy se ha logrado un
reconocimiento por parte de eeuu la gran
potencia el miembro permanente del
consejo de seguridad de la onu el actor
influyente en la escena internacional un
reconocimiento de la soberanía de
marruecos sobre todo su territorio
incluida las provincias del sur bajo
criterios y la suma en que yo mayor yo
no son de su ritual es poco probable que
la posición de washington cambie la de
la onu que pide en cambio un referendo
para resolver la disputa en sáhara
occidental mientras que los israelíes
celebra la decisión al mismo tiempo que
empezaron las festividades de janucá los
palestinos que pierden poco a poco el
apoyo del mundo árabe condenaron el
acuerdo de normalización de las
relaciones